ومن سوء تنضم الينا مراسله صباح العربيه
في جولاتها المستمره من سوق اشواق العتولي
اشواق يسعد صباحك اهلا بك حتى انت لابسه
ازرق في البيت الازرق اهلا بك المقر
الرسمي السابق لرئيس الكوري في تقليد ديما
74 عاما خذينا في جوله في البيت الازرق
صباح الخير
مع البيت الازرق والبس اللون الازرق لون
الولاء كما تعرفين ونحن الان في البيت
الازرق الذي سمي بهذا الاسم عام
1960 يعني هو رغم ان هو كان مقر لرؤساء من
عام 1948 لحد هذه السنه والرئيس الحالي
اللي غير مقر الرئاسه لاسباب يقال ان
السلطه يجب ان تكون اقرب الى الشعب هذا
المقر الذي خلف فيه هو طبعا المقر الرئيسي
من منطقه جدا كبيره كما ذكرت هو اكبر من
البيت الابيض بثلاث مرات يضم قاعه
للمؤتمرات والضيافه ويضم حديقه خاصه وهي
تعتبر اجمل ما يوجد في هذه المنطقه توجد
بها كثير من النباتات
التذكاريه الرؤساء وكذلك مسكن الرؤساء
نفسهم والجميل ايضا هناك قاعه تسمى بقاعه
الربيع والخريف وهي مخصصه للمؤتمرات
الصحفيه كما تعرف ممكن هنا يزين هذا المقر
الرئيسي البلاطات او القرميد الازرق همم
اكثر من 150000 قطعه موجوده ويمكن ان تعيش
لمئات السنين طمع التصميمها بطريقه خاصه
وعلى طراز همم طبعا الكوري همم الاسم تغير
عام 1960 مع احد الرؤساء والسبب يقال لانه
اراد ان يغير الصوره عن الرؤساء
الديكتاتوريون السابقين الان طبعا اهم
معظم الرؤساء هم ديمقراطيين وكوريا تعتبر
الدوله الديمقراطيه
والمميز في هذا القصر طبعا او البيت
الرئاسي انه طبعا قبل 1000 عام همم كان
مقر ملكي اصلا هو تابع لمملكه الجوسن منذ
الاف السنين همم ايضا وموقعه يعد
استراتيجي جدا لانهم محاط بالجبال هناك
اربع جبال تحيط به في الخلفي يوجد جبل على
الجانبين وفي الامام ايضا من مشكل موقع
امني يمكن وجود عقب فيه طبعا الجبل
الرئيسي الذي كان وراءه نعم طيب اشواق
اليوم المكتب الرئاسي نقل الى مجمع او
مجمع وزاره الدفاع هذا المبنى الذي انت
فيه او البيت الابيض بكل مبانيه موجود على
التل منزل هل تحول اليوم الى مزار
نعم اصبح الان مع نم سياحي يشهد الكثير من
الزوار طبعا منذ افتتاح في شهر خمسه هذا
العام كان طبعا في البدايه الجمهور استغرب
لكن تم ترحيب فيه كثير قرابه 800,000 شخص
تقريبا صار في غضون شهر شهر وشيء يعني
يوميا يزوره تقريبا 40,000 شخص واللي له
حتى صراحه امس انا قم بزيارته اليوم ان
بعضهم الزوار اللي يزورون هم من كبار السن
من كبار المواطنين الكوريين الذين استشعر
ارادوا ان يروا تاريخ بلادهم وكيف تاسست
الحكومه الكوريه وكيف عاشوا اسمائهم على
مدار السنين همم الماضيه همم طبعا في هذا
المكان او هذا الموقع عاش فيه تقريبا
ثلاثه عشر رئيس الين الرئيس الحالي
والذي غير هذا القرار همم ذهب الى همم
المقرر الاخر الذي يوجد في همم ينسى هناك
ايضا طبعا هذيك المنطقه همم كانت تعتبر
قريبا من همم القوات المس الامريكيه لذلك
فهي ايضا امنيا همم طبعا تعتبر همم جيده
الجميل ايضا ان حتى المنطقه او الجبال
التي كانت حوالين القصر كانت محظوره على
الناس التنزه بها لكن لاول مره الجبل
الخلفي منذ 54 عاما الان اصبح مسار متاح
للجمهور ل- اا طبعا للتنزه او التسلق همم
الجبال شكرا جزيلا لك من سوريا
على هذه الجوله الجميله في البيت الازرق